we are building costume racks for the
upstairs loft it's a complete mess we
need to get that straightened out so we
don't ruin all of our valuable costumes
they finished and it looks great
[Music]
hey
hey but like if we need we can put on
the rack here we're gonna need to we're
gonna need to do like rows like all the
way down so there's like mini rows
question for you for small stuff do we
have any like extra bins that i could
print labels for like elbow pads knee
pads got a ton of bins now we're trying
to figure out how to reorganize it all
there's no organization to it whatsoever
v-sauce it's like stuff you put on like
hamburgers and stuff right yes
and by hamburger you mean brain meat yes
for learning how heavy thor's hammer is
or what would happen if you get punched
by superman all very important things so
you want me to be the woman
who loses her bag right only the one
only actually the woman's at first i
want you to be the fear of her as as
with most of our videos it's like we
have a cool concept we have like a good
like beginning and don't really know
where to take it sometimes we start with
the ending and then we have to figure
out a beginning i'm not nearly as good
at coming up with ideas like this as sam
and nico are hey don't you say that
you're great a lot of your videos are
amazing all of your videos are amazing
not a lot not a lot all of them
superheroes video game heroes
the portals video mario kart on the
board on the skateboard
right now i'm just going through
everything trying to find every single
piece of bdu pants jackets put them
together in pairs
and then put them up here the key is to
take our time and be organized with it
it's looking pretty clean so far but
this place is going to be packed so we
have all our bdus uniforms and then we
have
vests tactical gear and then headgear
actually these are full sets of uniforms
so like you have the pants and the
jacket but we have an excess of pants
like by a lot so i think it's looking
pretty good it's pretty crammed up there
but it's gonna be way way way way more
easy to find like specific things that
you're looking for
still got a little pile going on there
that's the random stuff so yeah
civilian jackets fantasy video game
stuff emergency services like
firefighters some of our like period
costumes are here civilian t-shirts
random belt over here is all like the
military bdus like i said before lots of
excess pants cameras so theseus's ship
also known as the ship of the thief
of
the ship of theseus or grandfather's axe
is basically a paradox where let's say
we have a ship and we have the ship and
we remove every piece of it remove all
the wood remove the sails remove the
nails and we take all those pieces put
it aside and then we give it new wood
new sails new screws new nails is it the
same ship or is it a different ship and
then it gets a little bit more confusing
by let's say we so we've replaced all
the wood then we take the old wood and
we turn that into a ship using all the
same pieces from the old ship is this
new ship now the old ship and is the old
ship still the same ship which ship is
the old ship
there's like what's this it's just like
a
like a peasant shirt
oh yeah hey there you are
just in time i just finished putting the
labels on everything
boom
drink it in
all right
well
i think we're all done here here's a
quick little story then i'm gonna i'm
gonna leave you i promise no okay so my
friend or something he was talking to
his daughter the daughter was young
maybe like three or four years old he
was talking about like oh they're gonna
go talk to grandma later and she was
like oh are we gonna are we gonna call
grandma on the phone
he was like what are you doing what is
this
oh my gosh this is a phone like this is
a phone to people yet us older
generation folks still do this because a
phone looked like this but now people
are like oh yeah you're going to call
her on the phone and it's just a slab
that you put next to your face and also
side note what am i i'm gonna stop
calling this the iphone cause the phone
features the least used feature for me
finding an umbrella in southern
california
might be difficult yeah we'll see